we're back with more proof that South
Korea Does It Better the movie opens up
in a laboratory where a group of evil
men armed with metal pipes are brutally
attacking human bodies hidden beneath a
sheet shortly after the head of the
experiment Dr bayak arrives there and
suggests that they always aim for the
head following her orders the men
continue hitting the bodies despite a
few of them still moving in the midst of
the horrific scene two kids managed to
escape from the lab and Dr bayek's team
led by Dr Choi tries their best to catch
them after a bit of chasing they capture
one child named nobleman who mentions
that he tried to chase the girl but got
hurt by her instead hearing this Dr
bayak instructs Mr Choi to keep looking
for the girl as she is armed with
telekinetic abilities the following
morning not far from the laboratory a
farmer named coo notices the unconscious
girl near his field and rushes to help
her concerned he brings her inside his
house and together with his wife calls a
doctor for help the doctor assures them
that the girl will recover physically
but sadly won't be able to remember her
past life that's not sad that's
convenient 10 years go by and the little
girl has grown up and is now named
jayoon since KU and his wife could not
have children they decided to adopt her
now jiyun helps coo with Farm chores and
has become very close to her adoptive
mother who is showing early signs of
dementia moreover the family is facing
financial problems as the price of
cattle keeps dropping who discusses the
need to sell their cattle but jiyun
argues that selling at such low prices
would result in significant losses one
night after a quick shower jiyun suffers
from a severe migraine that brings her
to tears the pain is excruciating which
completely numbs her senses but
fortunately it doesn't last long and she
soon comes back to normalcy the
following day jiyun heads to school with
her best friend myung-hee out of the
blue the latter suggests that ja Yoon
should participate in an upcoming
singing competition which is offering a
hefty winning prize of five hundred
thousand dollars chayoon agrees right
away because winning could help pay for
her mom's hospital bills and solve their
money problems in the next Scene jyun
goes for the audition and surprisingly
scores the highest earning an invitation
to Seoul that night while watching her
audition with her family her parents
discover that she showcased telekinetic
abilities on TV this alarms them but
Myung hee defends her claiming that
special skills are popular nowadays she
also reassures them that everything will
be fine and that Giant's skills will
help her gain extra exposure before
bedtime jiyun Comforts her anxious
mother promising that she is doing all
of this to help them later that night
while my young he is sleeping soundly ja
Yoon experiences another headache
meanwhile Mr Choi secretly observes her
from a distance as her identity has been
exposed during the audition the next day
the girls take a train to Seoul for the
next phase of the audition during the
journey a young guy sitting in front of
them claims to know ja Yoon but our girl
doesn't remember him here we learned
that the guy is none other than noblemen
he even calls her Miss witch and tries
to slap her afraid Myung he screams and
makes a fuss even though she thought
this dude was real hot a second ago
which causes noblemen to leave but not
before he tells jyun that they will meet
again as he departs he bumps into a
middle-aged man and insults him when the
guy tries to retaliate nobleman brutally
finishes him off and tosses his body off
the train later upon reaching the studio
jayoon delivers an exceptional
performance this gains her a lot of
support from the judges and as a result
she secures a spot in the quarterfinals
elsewhere Dr bayak is also watching the
audition on TV she gently Smiles almost
as if she is happy to see the girl alive
meanwhile as ja Yoon enters a bathroom
she suffers yet another violent headache
this time she even faces a nosebleed
indicating that her illness is worsening
in a flashback we are shown that when
jayoon visited a doctor he informed her
that the headaches would likely claim
her life within two to three months the
only way to save her is a bone marrow
transplant from her biological parents
back to the present ja Yoon and young he
are getting late to return home and they
wait for a taxi outside the studio right
then Dr Bai X-Men approach the girls
attempting to kidnap them but
fortunately a group of children exit the
building at the same time and distract
the men seizing the opportunity the
girls get into their taxi and later take
a train to return home upon their
arrival at the station while Myung hee
contacts her dad for a ride nobleman
appears before jiyun and threatens her
warning that he will harm her parents if
she does not comply as soon as he leaves
a panicked jayoon urges her best friend
to call her dad for help myung-hee's Dad
Mr doe is a police officer and he visits
jiyun's house there he finds noblemen
and his group waiting for someone
sensing something amiss officer doe
politely requests their identification
and asks them to leave the premises
moments later the girls arrive home but
cannot find anyone inside the police car
panicked they Rush inside the house only
to find their fathers playing chess
together before leaving officer doe
inquires if jayoon knows the men who
visited her house and she replies with a
no elsewhere nobleman and his group
confront the professor who is a former
colleague of Dr bayax it is revealed
that he has recently broken off all ties
with the organization and is refusing to
cooperate in response nobleman with his
telekinetic abilities uses a gun and
kills the professor along with his
family afterward they set fire to his
house and to leave the scene at the next
day Dr bayak meets with Mr Choi and
suggests that he take a vacation in
Europe she also instructs him not to
interfere with her fairs again the
latter is unhappy with this decision but
ultimately complies with his superiors
orders before leaving he warns Dr bayak
about ji Yoon describing her as a
Monster who must be eliminated however
the doctor refuses to do so during
dinner jayoon's family expresses concern
about the mother's illness her dementia
is worsening and she can no longer
recognize even her daughter that night
jayoon is again awakened by intense pain
from another severe headache meanwhile
Dr biax men sneak into the house and
threaten jiyun's mom with a gun they
also take him young he as a hostage soon
ja Yoon becomes aware of the situation
and as she gets up she finds herself
surrounded by a group of armed men
initially jayoon tries to remain calm
and pleads with the men to go away but
when one of them makes a slight cut on
myung-hee's neck she becomes enraged and
unleashes her extraordinary abilities
she moves at the speed of light and
eliminates each one of Dr byx men
ruthlessly after the last goon is dead
jiyun realizes what she has done and
begins to panic at the same time
nobleman appears impressed by her true
abilities and explains that jayoon was
engineered differently he warns her that
if she doesn't follow him he will harm
everyone in the village he's just mad
that she's a better singer than him when
he clearly has the looks for a K-pop
dream in the meantime flashes of
memories rush back to jayune but they
are still insufficient for a complete
recollection of what transpired with her
in the past nobleman offers to help her
regain her memories but insists that she
must come with him hoping that the
laboratory can cure her brain disorder
jayoon agrees before leaving though she
requests myung-hee to take care of her
parents meanwhile Mr Choi assembles all
the field agents ready to assassinate
jayoon next nobleman and jayoon arrive
at an abandoned laboratory where Dr
bayak has been waiting jyun is then
brought to an interrogation room and
tied to a chair Dr bayak welcomes her
and communicates through a speaker from
the other room she reveals that she has
been looking for her for over a decade
they didn't look very hard though she
was at the first Farm down the street
following this Dr Baya gets straight to
the point promising to assist ja Yoon in
recovering her memories she then orders
her men to inject a serum into her as
the serum takes effect ja Yoon begins to
remember the experiments conducted on
her and the other children here it is
revealed that ja Yoon was one of the
experimental subjects and Dr bayak was
in charge of the whole operation the
entire experiment was conducted to
determine the brain's Supernatural
ability in the present Dr bayak claims
that she's now the world's top brain
specialist and that ja Yoon was one of
her most remarkable Creations
specifically trained to be a ruthless
killing machine she also warns jiyun
that her migraines are a symptom of
disease linked to her abilities and
without proper treatment her brain can
explode as the conversation continues
jiyun once again suffers from extreme
pain this causes her to bleed from
various organs and leaves her struggling
to breathe finally Dr bayax signals one
of her men to administer another serum
to jiyun claiming it is the only way to
save her from Death she also mentions
that the serum will restore her
abilities fully but its effects will
last only a month however jayoon's
reaction to the injection surprises
everyone she passes a creepy smile to
the doctor and reveals that she never
lost her memories in fact she was only
pretending so that she could get here
jayoon further reveals that she
intentionally showcased her talent in
the audition to draw the doctor's
attention now with her abilities fully
restored jahian begins to create chaos
suddenly she breaks free from her
restraints and eliminates Dr byx men in
the interrogation room in a desperate
attempt to thwart her the doctor orders
the release of nerve gas but to her
dismay jiyun Smiles at her takes a few
steps back and escapes through the
ceiling soon she reappears behind Dr
bayak and demands to know where the rest
of the serum vials are kept when the
latter hesitates she shoots her in the
kneecap meanwhile nobleman and his group
are on their way to the laboratory where
Mr Choi and his men intercept them a
fierce battle unfolds between the two
groups and Mr Choice men initially
gained the upper hand however a fighter
from nobleman's group named Harry girl
completely turned the tide hairy girl in
particular is lit in the next scene is
jiyun is dragging Dr bayak nobleman
catches up and suddenly attacks her he
warns her that he's not the same as
before and engages in a ferocious battle
but jiyun ultimately defeats him however
before she can finish him off Mr Choi
arrives at the scene and shoots her he
then turns towards the doctor and
without letting her say anything kills
her when he shifts his Focus back to
jiyun she is already recuperated from
the bullet wound and in the blink of an
eye she kills Mr Choi by ruthlessly
breaking his neck if she keeps killing
people there's not gonna be a part too
Mom Slater nobleman regains his
composure and informs jyun that they are
the only ones left he also reveals that
the remaining vials of the serum are in
the control room and speculates that the
headquarters research facility May
produce it while she is distracted
nobleman attempts to shoot jiyun in the
head but she sidesteps the attack and
repeatedly stabs him with a knife
ultimately ending his pretty boy life
later Jian successfully retrieves the
remaining vials of serum from the
control room and leaves but not before
setting the laboratory on fire she then
visits her adoptive parents at the
hospital and provides coup with the
serum to slow down her mother's dementia
she might also start throwing with
her mind and killing people though Fast
Forward by three months jiyun visits the
twin sister of Dr bayak the latter
recognizes her from her file and
provides her with a briefcase full of
blue serum however jiyun reveals that
she seeks a permanent solution to her
problem right then a scar-covered young
woman stands behind the doctor and the
movie ends with jayoon threatening to
kill the woman if she lays even a finger
on her
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching